I think businesses understood what they
needed to understand and that is that
their business models over attend to so
the businesses are responsible to their
stakeholders they don't answer to the
CEO or just the board that's kind of a
mythical you know simplistic view Oh
everyone answers to the CEO no they
actually answer to the stakeholders
stakeholders the stockholders and the
stock goes up and down based on their
confidence in a business's understanding
of the future and how to capitalize on
the future so all sudden people look at
Walmart hey it's growing great oh it's
doubling is tripling its buying this
nation everything else and you know
Walmart's growing great growth story
okay but at what cost oh there's you
know this issue of Labor here there's
this issue stock goes down all sudden
Walmart's understanding hope we can
actually decrease our costs by having
rice aronia maybe it's hamburger helper
noodles flat-packed like they do in ikea
to have the the packaging be smaller
save on shipping costs save on all these
things so they're going all the way the
bank so Walmart big huge monolith making
great business decisions saving money
good environmental decisions using less
paperless packing less fuel everything
that's a shift in business thinking all
of a sudden Walmart's making these kind
of decisions Walmart's a leader so that
when Walmart says something to their
supply chain in a sense they've said it
to the entire retail supply chain
clothing food everything huge huge
statement that's the last 18 months of
thing
you